hello and welcome to another episode of
footnotes in which I explore the most
ravishing language and ideas from the
last week of Wired first up today we're
being watched gadget lab reported on a
new analytics tool that they referred to
as the all-seeing eye but who's I is
this and what color is the eye I can't
speak to its color but I can say that
this all-seeing eye is the eye of God or
at least it has been historically it
seemed on the back of the one-dollar
bill so you're already familiar with it
unless of course you happen to be rich
in which case you didn't know the bills
came in one's also known as the Eye of
Providence the symbol evolved from the
Egyptian I of Horus Christianity adopted
it as a symbol for the Trinity and in
1776 it was included in a mock-up of the
Great Seal of the United States which
for some reason looks like it was drawn
on a cocktail napkin so above the eye on
the one-dollar bill is Latin that
basically says God is down with what
we're doing below the eye reads new
order for the ages because the founding
fathers were really looking forward to
electro-pop the all-seeing eye shows up
in a most excellent manner in the late
60 TV show then came Bronson in which
actor Michael parks rides a motorcycle
with the symbol painted on the side
parks had three years earlier starred as
Adam in the movie the Bible in the
beginning coincidence what was God
wanting to keep an eye on the beautiful
california coast and occasionally the
sight of a station wagon next up honey i
shrunk the pachyderms wired science
explored the evolution of a komodo
dragon which is thought to have one
sprayed on pygmy elephants on the
islands of Indonesia so a pygmy species
is just a smaller version of an animal
but where does the word pygmy come from
it derives from the Greek meaning so
adorbs no doesn't Amy's dwarf in Greek
mythology the pygmies were only about a
foot tall and legend has it that they
once swarmed a sleeping Hercules only
can be scooped up and kidnapped compare
this to the scene in Gulliver's Travels
in which the tiny Lilliputians succeed
in capturing Gulliver
having learned a thing or two from the
attack on Hercules the term pig meat has
also been used to describe various
peoples who happen to be shorter than
the Europeans who stumbled into their
villages these explorers couldn't help
but take a picture with the pit knees
like this guy who thought it'd be funny
to appear even taller by wearing a hat
in the 1880s fellow hat enthusiasts and
explorer Henry Stanley the guy who found
Livingston in Africa medi picnic couple
the woman he described as a miniature
Eve and wrote that the man had a mimic
dignity as of Adam as it happens this
pygmy man was portrayed by Michael parks
in the smash hit the Bible in the
beginning